[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen wir beginnen mit
einem wahren Krimi in der Ostsee es sind
offenbar sehr große Lex die da gestern
plötzlich in die Gaspipelines nordstream
1 und 2 gerissen wurden jedenfalls gab
es einen explosionsartigen Druckabfall
es gibt in der Nähe der Insel Bornholm
Gefahr für die Schifffahrt und es gibt
viele offene Fragen die beiden Pipelines
stehen ja seit Monaten im Zentrum der
Energiekrise sie liefern beide aktuell
kein Gas und werden das nach den legs
jetzt wohl sehr lange auch nicht mehr
tun das all das Zufall sein soll daran
glaubt kaum noch jemand Susanne Seidel
berichtet
es können keine kleinen legs sein die
solche Gasmassen auf einmal freisetzen
Aufnahmen des dänischen Militärs zeigen
wie mit hohem Druck Gas aus
verschiedenen Löchern an die Oberfläche
steigt es bringt die Ostsee auf mehreren
hundert Metern zum Schäumen es sind drei
Lecks aufgetreten in dem Pipelines von
Nord Stream 1 und 2 innerhalb von 24
Stunden alle in dänischen und
schwedischen wirtschaftsgewässern an den
Lex herrscht Explosionsgefahr die
dänischen Behörden reagieren bereits um
Unfälle zu vermeiden
wir sind natürlich dabei das Gebiet zu
sichern damit keine Schiffe hineinfahren
dafür sorgen die Armee und die dänische
seeschifffahrtsbehörde
schwedische Seismologen hatten im Laufe
des Montags starke Erschütterungen in
dem Gebiet gemessen denn relativ
zufrieden es handelt sich also um eine
relativ große Explosion bzw Sprengung
und aus den Wellenformen geht eindeutig
hervor dass es sich erstens nicht um ein
Erdbeben handelt und zweitens um etwas
das sich im Wasser oder in Bodennähe
ereignet hat
gewaltige Erschütterungen in der Ostsee
aber kein Seebeben die dänische
Ministerpräsidentin schließt Sabotage
nicht aus
es gibt drei Lecks auch mit etwas
Abstand dazwischen und deshalb ist es
schwer vorstellbar dass das was passiert
ein Zufall ist
ersten Medienberichten zufolge soll der
amerikanische Geheimdienst die
Bundesregierung schon im Sommer vor
möglichen Anschlägen auf die Pipelines
gewarnt haben
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
will sich öffentlich nicht an
Spekulationen beteiligen doch die
Situation in Europa entwickle sich mit
einer gewissen Dramatik natürlich ist
die kritische Infrastruktur ein
potenzielles Ziel aber das wissen wir
nicht erst seit gestern deutschland ist
ein Land das sich wohl zu verteidigen
weiß und Europa ist ein Kontinent das
seine Energieinfrastruktur schützen kann
und das tun alle Behörden
die russische Regierung schließt nach
Angaben eines kremlsprechers einen
Sabotageakt nicht aus man wolle aber
erst die Untersuchungen in der Ostsee
abwarten Spezialisten aus Deutschland
Schweden und Dänemark versuchen derweil
mit Hochdruck die Ursache für die lex
aufzuklären die europäische
Versorgungssicherheit ist laut
Bundesnetzagentur durch die beschädigten
Pipelines nicht beeinträchtigt
sprechen und zwar mit Frank Umbach er
ist Experte für Energiesicherheit an der
Uni Bonn guten Abend Herr Umbach
willkommen zurück im heute journal hallo
Herr Sievers guten Abend haben Sie denn
eine Erklärung wie kann es zu solchen
legs gleichzeitig kommen verbunden mit
Detonationen kann sowas Zufall sein oder
ein Unfall nein eindeutig nicht
also solche Zufälle auch das Faktum das
diese Lex teilweise 50 km hier
auseinander liegen und gleichzeitig fast
gleichzeitig ja zwei Pipelines betroffen
haben auch die Explosionen direkt
registriert worden sind die
unterwasserexplosionen sprechen
eindeutig dafür dass das in der Tat eine
sabotage-akt war und nicht irgendein
technischer Unfall irgendwie ist der
passiert passieren kann wir haben ja
ohnehin mit der nordstream 2 Pipeline
eine Pipeline die noch gar nicht im
Betrieb war die nagelneu sozusagen
verlegt worden ist und das ausgerechnet
da
Unfälle auftreten und vor allem in dem
Ausmaß auch auftreten ist völlig
politisch völlig unglaubwürdig und die
russische Regierung hat ja auch
offiziell schon wieder das versucht zu
rechtfertigen damit dass das sozusagen
Folge der westlichen Sanktionen sei dass
ich genügend Ersatzteile zur Verfügung
stehen würden etc das kennen wir mit der
Stilllegung der nordstream 1 Pipeline
diese politisch Stoßrichtung
Sabotageakt ist wahrscheinlich sagen sie
der schwedische Außenminister äußert
sich auch gerade in diese Richtung wer
könnte denn das ist ja dann die
Anschlussfrage ein Interesse an sowas
haben klar es heute sind die Gasmärkte
die Gaspreise wieder nach oben gegangen
und das bringt natürlich enorme
Verunsicherung in die Märkte rein das
ist richtig allerdings wird das nur
kurzfristig passieren weil beide
Pipelines haben ja bis zuletzt sozusagen
ja noch gar kein Gas mehr transportiert
also insoweit ist auch die Versorgung
Sicherheit Deutschlands sich davon
betroffen eine Erklärung könnte
möglicherweise auch sein dass im
Zusammenhang steht mit einer sogenannten
Baltic Pipeline die von Norwegen über
Dänemark nach Polen geht und die in den
nächsten Tagen anfangen oktober in
Betrieb genommen werden soll und mit der
wird es Polen möglich sein sich
endgültig von russischen Gaslieferungen
für die eigene Versorgung Sicherheit
unabhängig zu machen und insoweit hat
diese Pipeline eine hohe Bedeutung
sowohl für Polen als auch die EU als
eben auch als Storm sozusagen für die
Russische Föderation und diese Baltic
Pipeline die verläuft südlich von
Bornholm und kreuzt sich sozusagen mit
den beiden nordstream 1 und nordstream 2
Pipelines unter Wasser und deswegen ist
die polnische Regierung auch heute
insbesondere besorgt dass möglicherweise
auch ein Sabotage bevorsteht gegenüber
der Baltic Pipeline die jetzt gerade in
den nächsten Tagen in Betrieb gehen soll
bleiben wir noch mal im Moment bei den
aktuellen Lex die wir da sehen auch
diese Bilder in der Ostsee das sind ja
Bilder die man überhaupt nicht kennt die
man niemals jemals so gesehen hat wie
gefährlich ist denn so ein Leck was
genau strömt denn da jetzt aktuell aus
und sorgt für diese Blasen an der
Oberfläche also auch die nordstream 2
Pipeline die ja nicht in Betrieb
gegangen ist ist aber gefüllt worden und
damit hat man auch versucht von
russischer Seite Druck auf die deutsche
Bundesregierung auszuüben weil man
gesagt hat seht her die Pipeline ist
gebaut die ist fertig wir haben sie
sogar mit Gas gefüllt und deswegen hat
man im letzten Sommer bereits die ist
als als erpressungsmaterial benutzt zu
einem Zeitpunkt als Russland gesagt hat
wir liefern euch jetzt kein weiteres Gas
für die Auffüllung der Gasspeicher aber
wir tun es gerne wenn ihr sofort zu
schnell wie möglich die Zertifizierung
der nordstream 2 Pipeline beendet und
zwar bevor die neue Bundesregierung in
Amt und Würden kommt und dieser
pressungsstrategie haben wir im letzten
Jahr schon gesehen und insoweit gibt es
da ein russisches das Interesse glaube
ich mit Blick auch auf die Gaspreise
auch wenn die Wirkung sehr sehr
kurzfristig sein wird aber Putin hat den
Konflikt mit der Ukraine auch in
Richtung Westen auch damit
entsprechend eskaliert noch mal kurz die
Frage wie gefährlich ist das was da
ausströmt aktuell also das ist normales
Gas was da ausströmen das ist auch
Methangas das ist natürlich
klimapolitisch eher eine Katastrophe ja
aber und es ist natürlich kann auch für
die Schifffahrt gefährlich sein aber
darüber hinaus sozusagen ist es zunächst
mal so nicht weiter gefährlich ganz kurz
noch Herr Umbach wir haben nicht mehr
viel Zeit wird jemals wieder Gasströmen
oder sind nordstream 1 und 2 mit dem
heutigen Tag Geschichte
ich glaube sie waren schon vorher
Geschichte und mit dem heutigen Tag wird
sich die Bundesregierung ihrer
Entscheidung entsprechend bestätigt
fühlen und das gilt natürlich auch für
die EU und natürlich Fohlen
beispielsweise die in die betrieblichen
eine solche Inbetriebnahme von
nordstream 2 niemals zustimmen würde von
Grumbach Experte für Energiesicherheit
Uni Bonn herumbacher heute Abend wieder
herzlichen Dank für ihre Expertise ja
bitteschön schönen Abend noch in auch
danke wie sehr Energie unser Leben
bestimmt das bekommen wir aktuell jeden
Tag neu vorgeführt auch gerade eben
wieder den Bundeswirtschaftsminister
hält nichts so sehr in Atem wie die
exorbitant gestiegenen Energiepreise er
muss ja gerade suchen nach einer
Nachfolgelösung für die gescheiterte
gasumlage professionell gemanagt ist was
anderes und auch die Sicherheit der
Stromversorgung macht zunehmend Sorgen
Robert Habeck erwartet jetzt das zwei
deutsche Kernkraftwerke zumindest im
ersten Quartal nächsten Jahres
laufen der geplante Komplettausstieg aus
der Atomkraft ist damit zumindest
gebremst Andreas Huppert
er geht ein bisschen unter in der Menge
er verschwindet aus dem Fokus und fast
scheint es so als genieße Robert Habeck
diese Situation ich permanent im
Mittelpunkt der Kritik zu stehen Hamburg
heute morgen Eröffnung der
internationalen Wind Energiemesse Habeck
spricht in Englisch zum Ausbau grüner
Energie zum drängendsten deutschen
Problem der Gasversorgung allerdings
kein Wort dabei hatte er der Deutschen
Presseagentur die energiepreiskrise in
düsteren Worten skizziert
teilt ist es erst ein spielbrand teils
brennt schon die Hütte
in jedem Fall ist die Zukunftsfähigkeit
unserer Wirtschaft in Gefahr ist drohen
Dauerschäden
das was der Wirtschaftsminister
feststellt ist zum Alltag der
energieintensiven Wirtschaft geworden
Beispiel die Firma simpelkamp in Krefeld
Weltmarktführer in Sachen großguss
deshalb können Sie hier die teuren
Energiepreise auf die Kunden umlegen
noch
wir brauchen Leitplanken zum Thema Strom
zum Thema Entkopplung Gas zum Strom
solange wir keine Klarheit haben wird es
für uns schwierig
klare Ansage an die Politik macht
endlich voran trefft Entscheidungen den
Rest machen wir hauptsache es gibt
ausreichend Strom und Gas und zwar
bezahlbar daran feilt die
Bundesregierung habecks geplante
gasumlage ist längst tot jetzt soll es
der gaspreisdeckel richten wie das
wollte der Kanzler morgen mit den
Ländern besprechen doch Scholz hat
Corona die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz fällt aus
wir wünschen ihm schnelle und gute
Genesung sind allerdings der Auffassung
dass in der angespannten Situation in
der unser Land ist auch eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz virtuell
möglich gewesen wäre und auch aus den
Ländern kommt druckschnelle Lösungen
brauche es jetzt Niedersachsen
präsentiert gar ein eigenes Modell für
eine gaspreisbremse der grundgedankte
ist fifty-fifty der Staat verpflichtet
sich die Hälfte der
Energiepreissteigerung zu übernehmen die
andere Hälfte verbleibt bei den
Verbraucherinnen und Verbrauchern sowohl
in den privaten Haushalten wie in der
Wirtschaft die AFD sitzt auf Kernenergie
will nicht nur die alten Meile am Netz
lassen sondern
respektivisch natürlich auch Bau neuer
Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland um den
Energiebedarf zu decken so weit geht
Robert Habeck nicht als er am Abend dann
doch wieder in den Mittelpunkt rückt der
grüne Wirtschaftsminister schafft die
Voraussetzungen um Atomkraft in
Deutschland länger nutzen zu können
diese Eckpunkte und dann das spätere
Gesetz sichern die Verf Dankbarkeit der
beiden Atomkraftwerke in der Karl
Westheim und Isa 2 nach dem Ende des
laufzeitbetriebes Ende diesen Jahres für
die Monate Januar Februar März bis Mitte
April für den Bereich Strom hat habe
jetzt also eine Entscheidung getroffen
für Gas steht sie noch aus die Absage
der morgigen Konferenz mit den Ländern
bringt ihm zumindest eines zusätzliche
Zeit
es gibt Wahlen da wartet man voller
Neugier auf das Ergebnis und es gibt
Wahlen da steht das Ergebnis schon
vorher fest das sind natürlich keine
echten Wahlen keine wirkliche Auswahl
aber sie werden gerne dennoch benutzt um
politische Entscheidungen scheinbar zu
legitimieren in mehreren besetzten
ukrainischen Gebieten haben die
russischen Besatzer Hals über Kopf
solche pseudoabstimmungen durchgeführt
und heute erste Ergebnisse präsentiert
die verschlagen jetzt niemandem den Atem
87 92 97 Prozent sind für einen Beitritt
zu Russland was jetzt folgt sorgt
allerdings für große Befürchtungen
Russland dürfte das Ergebnis als Vorwand
nehmen um sich diese Gebiete offiziell
einzuferleiben Torgebäude berichtet
noch einmal sind Ludmilla und oleksandre
nach ulrichew gekommen sie wollen nach
dem Rechten sehen und Winterkleidung
holen im Mai hatten sie den Ort
fluchtartig verlassen als die russische
Armee anfing oder ich es zu bombardieren
puh hier stinkt es aber ganz schön
furchtbar die Lebensmittel vergammelt
die Schränke durch die Druckwelle
zahlreicher Bomben verzogen und kaputt
nur einen Ort weiter wurde in den
letzten Tagen über den Anschluss an
Russland abgestimmt auf die Frage danach
werden beide ungehalten wir wollen das
nicht wir sind nur für die Ukraine ich
bin 82 Jahre alt ich kann nicht kämpfen
aber ich könnte im Graben sitzen und den
Soldaten die Waffen reichen ich hätte
nie gedacht dass ich so hassen kann
hier bleiben wollen sie derzeit nicht
fast täglich schlagen Raketen oder
riechef ein
zwei Drittel der Einwohner sind weg der
Ort liegt nur vier Kilometer von der
Frontlinie entfernt dahinter beginnt der
von Russland besetzte Teil von saporisha
viele haben Freunde und Verwandte auf
der anderen Seite die abstimmen mussten
meine Schwester wohnt drüben in Berg ich
kann Sie telefonisch aber nicht
erreichen wieso soll unser Territorium
zu Russland gehören wir wollen unsere
Ukraine zum Bezirk riechef gehören sechs
Ortschaften nur drei sind unter
ukrainischer Kontrolle Anatoli ist der
Bürgermeister das Schicksal seiner
Landsleute auf der anderen Seite kennt
er nur von Erzählungen der Menschen die
geflohen sind und der fürchtet dass es
nach dem Schein Referendum noch
schlimmer wird
die Leute sollten flüchten denn es wird
nichts Gutes passieren gar nichts
entweder geht die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive weiter oder die Russen
terrorisieren wieder die Bevölkerung
trotz dieses Referendums trotz ihrer
verzweifelten Bemühungen demokratisch
und zivilisiert auszusehen aber das sind
sie nicht
Ludmila und Alexandra werden sich wieder
auf den Weg machen schweren Herzens dass
sie orichef ihre Heimat verlassen müssen
tut weh
wir werden auf die Befreiung warten
damit wir nach Hause zurückkehren können
ja
ich würde gerne in meinem eigenen Land
sterben ich werde nicht ewig leben und
ich will neben meiner ersten Frau auf
unserem Friedhof begraben sein und sie
dem ihren ersten Mann
meine Stadt in meine Wohnung in mein
Bett
Soldaten und Politiker sie werden
entscheiden wie es nur riechef in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen weitergeht
ja und die werden interessant was kommt
jetzt Christian semmes für uns in Moskau
Christian guten Abend alle erwarten das
Präsident Putin all diese Gebiete in
Russland einverleiben wird wie schnell
kann denn so etwas jetzt gehen
ja das kann jetzt schnell gehen zwei
Gebiete haben ja schon den Sieg bei
diesen umstrittenen Referenten verkündet
die anderen beiden werden bald folgen
und dann kann das jetzt relativ schnell
hier in Gesetze gegossen werden die dann
den Anschluss an die Russische
Föderation beinhalten und viele
Beobachter gehen jetzt davon aus dass
Vladimir Putin am Freitag schon sich mit
einer Ansprache ans Volk wenden könnte
und dann die Annexion dieser Gebiete
verkünden könnte und damit wäre dann ein
großes Ziel erreicht was Russland jetzt
in der letzten Zeit immer wieder betont
hat der Präsident auch selbst nämlich
wenn es weitere Kämpfe gibt weitere
Angriffe dann würden die nun auf
russischen Staatsgebiet stattfinden und
die würde man mit entsprechender Härte
zurückschlagen wie käme denn so eine
Annexion bei den russischen Russen an
ist nicht so ganz einfach zu beantworten
ich würde sagen die die der Propaganda
folgen die sagen natürlich dass das eine
gute Idee ist weil die Gebiete acht
Jahre von Neonazis terrorisiert wurden
und jetzt befreit werden mussten die
anderen die dagegen sind auch die die
gegen eine teilmobilisierung sind ja die
halten lieber den Mund weil sie wissen
dass das gefährlich ist weil über diese
Frage wird ja hier kein Diskurs geführt
wir haben die Proteste gesehen die
wurden niedergeschlagen also es gibt
hier kein öffentliches Forum sich zu
äußern was wir aber sehen sind diese
großen Menschenmassen die sich aus
Russland wegbewegen an der finnischen
Grenze an der Grenze zu Georgien oder
auch zum Mongolei das sind 10.000
Menschen die gehen und ich glaube das
ist ein ganz deutliches Zeichen dass man
damit nicht einverstanden ist und auch
dieser Mobilisierung ganz klar entgehen
will eine Mobilisierung der ganz anderen
Art sozusagen Christian ganz herzlichen
Dank wir sprechen mit Sicherheit gegen
Ende der Woche wieder miteinander
Christian Selm ZDF Moskau war das und
jetzt nach Deutschland wo der Chef der
größten oppositionsparte haben wir heute
viel Empörung ausgelöst hat und zwar
quer durch alle Parteien
es geht um eine
aussagt März hatte behauptet die
Kriegsflüchtlinge würden sich das System
zu nutze machen und zwischen Deutschland
und der Ukraine hin und her pendeln nach
heftiger Kritik entschuldigte sich der
CDU-Vorsitzende heute und erklärte dass
er die Verwendung des Wortes bedauere
laut der Bundesagentur für Arbeit gibt
es keine Hinweise auf einen
umfangreichen Missbrauch von
unterstützungsgeldern durch ukrainische
geflüchtete
Tschechien hat temporäre Kontrollen an
der Grenze zur Slowakei angekündigt
damit soll laut Ministerpräsident Fiala
illegale Migration gestoppt werden
hintergrund ist ein Anstieg der
migrantenzahlen seit Anfang des Jahres
waren es noch offiziellen Angaben etwa
12.000 die meisten davon sollen Syrer
sein die Grenzkontrollen zwischen den
beiden Ländern die beide zum
visumsfreien Schengen Raum gehören
sollen mindestens zehn Tage andauern und
am Donnerstag beginnen
eine neue Studie hat umfassend
sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder in
Sportvereinen dokumentiert vor allem im
Leistungs- und wettkampforientierten
breiten Sport gab es demnach
Kindesmissbrauch dazu zählten schwere
körperliche sexuelle Übergriffe und
Vergewaltigungen aber auch Schläge und
emotionale Gewalt grundlage sind 72
Erfahrungsberichte von Betroffenen laut
der Studie würden nur die wenigsten
Fälle aufgedeckt und aufgearbeitet drei
Viertel der Opfer sein weiblich ein
Viertel männlich
rund drei Monate nach seiner Ermordung
in Japan ist Japans früherer
regierungschefchen zu aber mit einem
Staats Begräbnis geehrt worden an der
Trauerfeier in Tokio nahmen hochrangige
Gäste aus aller Welt Teil unter ihnen
us-vizepräsidentin Harris ab war am 8
Juli während einer Wahlkampfrede
erschossen worden der rechtskonservative
Politiker war im eigenen Land umstritten
mehrere tausend Menschen protestierten
gegen die staatlich finanzierte
Trauerfeier
und jetzt ins All und zu einer Gefahr
die uns womöglich eines Tages bevorsteht
ein Asteroid trifft unsere Erde wie im
Hollywood-Film schon ein 50 Meter großer
Brocken könnte dann eine ganze Stadt
zerstören mit einem zehnmal größeren
anfliegenden Himmelskörper rechnet man
zwar nur alle hunderttausend Jahre doch
das wäre dann eine unfassbare
Katastrophe und deswegen hat die NASA
vergangene Nacht ein Gegenmittel geprobt
und einen 11 Millionen Kilometer
entfernten eigentlich harmlosen
Asteroiden ins Visier genommen um ihn
mit solch einer Sonde zu treffen die
Hoffnung Aufprall und rückschlagende
Staubwolke können die Flugbahn eines
Asteroiden entscheidend verändern
das wäre die Rettung für uns und für
unsere Erde und die Übung im All wurde
ein spektakulärer Volltreffer aus
Washington Ulrike Rüttler
s oh mein gott schaut euch das an es ist
unglaublich
es ist der Moment den man für die
US-Weltraumbehörde NASA historisch
nennen kann die Sonde Daten nähert sich
dem Asteroiden mischen er komplett der
Aufprall ist geglückt
also ich muss sagen ich habe wirklich
ein paar Tränen vergossen das letzte
Bild war zwar nicht so deutlich es waren
eine Menge Emotionen im Spiel wir hatten
ein paar kritische Momente aber ich muss
sagen es war eine tolle Zusammenarbeit
im Team
vor zehn Monaten war die Sonde von
Kalifornien aus ins All gestartet Kosten
für das nasa-projekt umgerechnet 337
Millionen Euro
wir erwarten von dem Experiment einige
Erkenntnisse wir werden uns den Krater
näher anschauen aber das wichtigste Ziel
ist dass der Asteroid seine Umlaufbahn
ändert wenigstens ein bisschen unsere
Modellrechnungen legen es nahe
wie wichtig dieses Projekt ist zeigen
diese Bilder aus Russland dort stürzten
2013 Brocken eines Asteroiden auf eine
Stadt und verletzten etwa 1000 Menschen
die NASA hat deshalb mit ihrem
Experiment heute Pionierarbeit geleistet
und ist ihrem Ziel die Erde zu schützen
ein klein wenig näher gekommen
ab 500 Meter könnte es richtig kritisch
werden und dann denke man natürlich an
die Kilometer großen Brocken die vor
65/66 Millionen Jahren zum Aussterben
der Dinosaurier geführt haben das ist
dann ein globaler Killer und so einem
Killer aus seiner Bahn zu schieben das
bedarf noch ein bisschen mehr als das
was wir momentan haben aber diese
datenmission ist eben ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Anfang
und so beginnt jetzt die eigentliche
Forschungsarbeit Teleskope wie zum
Beispiel das James Web Teleskop sollen
zeigen wie sich der Asteroid nun verhält
mit Ergebnissen rechnen die
Wissenschaftler in zwei Monaten
wenn er seine Umlaufbahn um weniger als
10 Grad ändert dann wissen wir ob das
Prinzip funktioniert
die europäische Weltraumbehörde ESA ist
an dem Projekt beteiligt und will in
zwei Jahren mit ihrer sonderheera den
Krater auf dem Asteroiden untersuchen
auch wenn für die nächsten 100 Jahre mit
keinem Einschlag zu rechnen ist so ist
der Erfolg heute trotzdem ein
Meilenstein und auch das ist eine gute
Nachricht
ja aber auch gut dass ich gerade noch
mal gehört habe das für die nächsten 100
Jahre mit keinem Einschlag zu rechnen
ist
noch mal Hanna
die Zinsen sie steigen mit
teuren hier finanzieren wollen und das
wiederum beschert jetzt dem guten alten
Bausparvertrag Vertrag ein echtes
Revival Valerie Haller in Frankfurt was
genau steckt dahinter ja so tatsächlich
die Zinswende und die insgesamt stark
gestiegenen Kosten all das macht die
Menschen natürlich deutlich
preissensibler seit Jahresanfang haben
sich die Zinsen für Immobilien
Finanzierung in der Spitze mehr als
verdreifacht die Zinsen von
Bausparverträgen hingegen sind
weitgehend konstant geblieben außerdem
sind sie aktuell auch meist günstiger
und man kann sich die Zinskonditionen
für bis zu 15 Jahre absichern all das
trägt dazu bei dass der Bausparvertrag
ein Comeback feiert zum Vergleich ein
klassischer Baukredit mit zehnjähriger
Laufzeit kostet zurzeit im Schnitt 3,6
Prozent bei den Bausparkasse liegen die
Darlehenszinsen ungefähr zwischen 1,5
und 2,5 Prozent bauen ist deutlich
teurer geworden nicht nur wegen der
gestiegenen Zinsen auch die Kosten für
Materialien sind gestiegen
Lieferengpässe ziehen den Bau in die
Länge
Normalverdiener können sich kaum mehr
ein Haus leisten nach Jahren Boom-Phase
kühlt sich die Nachfrage spürbar ab
Baufirmen erleben das aktuell viele
Aufträge storniert werden da kann der
Bausparvertrag eine Möglichkeit sein
wenigstens die steigenden Zinsen
abzufedern und dennoch lohnt er sich
nicht für jeden weil unter anderem
gebührenanfallen vor allem bei höheren
darlehensummen ist es schon ganz ratsam
genau nachzurechnen vielen Dank Valerie
für diese Einordnung
der Lufthansa Konzern will sich von
seinen Anteilen am russischen Airline
Caterer aeromar trennen und reagiert
damit auf heute veröffentlichte
Recherchen des
zdf-politikmagazins frontal über eine
Tochterfirma hält die Lufthansa bisher
49 Prozent an dem Caterer die staatliche
russische Fluggesellschaft Aeroflot
besitzt die restlichen 51% der
Firmenanteile der ukrainische
Außenminister Kollege hatte die
Beteiligung zuvor scharf kritisiert
es ist ein neuer bevölkerungsrekord in
Deutschland leben erstmals mehr als 84
Millionen Menschen was laut dem
Statistischen Bundesamt vor allem mit
den geflüchteten aus der Ukraine
zusammenhängt die in Deutschland Schutz
gesucht haben im ersten Halbjahr 2022
wuchs die Einwohnerzahl um rund
843.000 Personen das größte Plus gab es
in Berlin Bayern und Hessen zum
Vergleich im Gesamtjahr 2021 war die
Bevölkerungszahl bundesweit nur um
82.000 gestiegen
Hurrikan ihren hat mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 200
Kilometer pro Stunde Kuba erreicht und
dort Überschwemmungen und Schäden
angerichtet in den besonders betroffenen
Gebieten im Westen Kubas entwurzelte der
Hurrikan Bäume und zerstörte Häuser etwa
50.000 Menschen wurden in Sicherheit
gebracht ihren könnte Meteorologen
zufolge auf seinem Weg Richtung USA noch
an Kraft zulegen
US-Bundesstaat Florida wurde vorsorglich
der Ausnahmezustand ausgerufen
so mein ereignisreicher nachrichtentag
hier im heute journal geht zu Ende wir
freuen uns auch morgen wieder auf Sie
und mit unserem heute-journal-update
bleiben Sie auf dem neuesten
nachrichtenstand gegen Mitternacht mit
Kristina von Ungarn Sternberg vom
gesamten Team ein angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend in Mitteleuropa bleibt es
unbeständig denn da zieht ein Tief hier
von Dänemark weiter Richtung Schottland
und ein weiteres von Frankreich nach
Oberitalien heute Nacht fällt bei uns
Regen und allenfalls zwischen Hannover
Berlin und Dresden bleibt es
wahrscheinlich trocken die Temperaturen
dazu sinken auf 10 bis 3 Grad und
steigen morgen auf 8 bis 15 Grad am
mindesten wird es am Niederrhein über
Norddeutschland ziehen morgen etliche
Regenschauer hinweg zwischendurch werden
sie aber auch mal die Sonne sehen ganz
im Süden dagegen schüttelt es kräftig im
Süden Baden-Württembergs und in Bayern
auch der Donnerstag wird noch sehr
wechselhaft am Freitag ist es schon
deutlich milder und es fällt kaum noch
Regen am Samstag wird es dann von
Nordwesten richtig stürmisch und im
Norden genauer in Hamburg beginnt morgen
der 12
Extremwetterkongress die deutsche
Fachtagung zum Extremwetter im
Klimawandel
dieser Sommer war extrem heiß und dürr
dennoch mit lokalen Überschwemmungen
kein Wunder schließlich wird es auf der
Erde nicht nur insgesamt wärmer sondern
auch die extremen nehmen weiter zu so
hat sich die Anzahl heißer Tage mit
mindestens 30 Grad bei uns seit den
1950er Jahren verdreifacht von
durchschnittlich 3 auf 9 Tage hält sich
Hitze in einer Region mehr als drei Tage
nennen wir das Hitzewelle davon gab es
dieses Jahr gleich mehrere dazu die
Dürre immer wieder brachen Wald und
feldbrände aus die Hitze setzte auch
Deutschlands fünf kleinen Gletschern zu
sie schmolzen dahin jetzt sind es nur
noch vier das Eis des fünften nämlich
bewegt sich nicht mehr ist in eins zwei
Jahren wahrscheinlich ganz weg immerhin
war der September deutlich zu nass und
mal nicht deutlich zu warm guten Abend